we have this game called top that each
of you have to one-up each other and I
have three questions for you here's the
first one
what's the craziest thing you've done
for a video got naked you i sat in a
coffin made for me pretend it to be dead
and yeah okay make it is almost good I'm
sorry I'm gonna give that to him usually
I like give you a bow you gave me Oh
what is the biggest splurge but like
what happened I spent your money on it I
I mean this unclothed in general like
like like this jacket the shoes guess
it's more it's not it wasn't one
singular thing but it was a collection
of things they say when they follow me
bows there are Nintendo toys so yeah you
would like I started with one I bought
one when I was in New York and I went
will stop here I've got 60 of them well
some of them are like $10 and then my
friend got me one from Canada which is
worth about $70 something like that but
now here's your chance like what's one
thing you know you're a better out there
yeah well now I know I'm better out than
D directing there you go but that's
that's not like a thing in life is it as
just like oh sure you know you're not
like you're like going for that either
doesn't count
right oh yeah oh oh oh these are falling
apart here we had one drink I can fix it
we've did it I can fix it do they
actually fall oh my